none
Listen to my
story This
is the story and theme of these guys The injustice of Kaminarimon Country
[music]
Weiss The guy who talked to me the other day
Let's go
Game Chucky
Yes,
we want to take that story with a grain of salt, but I
think there are actually a lot of people who are dissatisfied.
It's
hard to write about the scene in a decent way
There may be people like that
I don't
like that I want to improve the things in front of me little by little By changing my mind, I'm
sure
I want to create a village where everyone can live with smiles on their faces Minwoo, can
you lend me your strength
Let's write this together
[Music]
Applause]
[music]
Shake me too